you've probably seen him every day on
the talk before you tune in to las vegas
now but now we have the ultimate
crossover jerry sat down with jillian to
talk about this past year's hosting the
show what project he's looking forward
to now and his special connection to las
vegas take a look i actually come to
vegas a lot i live in los angeles
um i'm married to rebecca romain who's a
famous actress and we actually
met in las vegas it was before you way
before your time it was um there was a
magazine called maxum magazine and they
would have parties called the maxim hot
100 and they had it at the hard rock
hotel and casino
and my wife was like top 10
in the hot 100 and i was
not
uh i was like
i was where all the civilians have to
hang out my wife was in the vip area and
i met her once before
and i was like waving like crazy and she
came over and i like snuck into the vip
area and i sat down with her and her
friends
and um
her friend said hey take her phone
number i could tell that she liked you
and i got her phone number and that's
how we met wow i had no idea so vegas
holds a really special place in our
heart from falling in love in vegas to
landing the role on the talk jerry
o'connell is grateful for all of his
experiences well happy one year
anniversary what has the whole
experience been like you have amazing
co-hosts and it seems like you're just
having fun every day that is really fun
it's fun to go to work and just um i
mean i hate to say this there's not a
lot of like
work involved like
i show up
a couple hours ahead of time
and
we talk about our subjects sort of
lightly and i say what i may or may not
say
and then we just do it live i mean
in the words of bill o'reilly we'll do
it live we'll do it live
we'll do it live i'll write it myself
and do it live when you're on in our
makeup room every day before we start
our show there's jerry there's jerry and
don't don't
watch me to get like a temperature of
what you should be doing out there on
the air like do whatever i'm doing do
the opposite do the opposite he's
obviously doing something right which
led him out here to las vegas so i'm
actually here in vegas because they have
a big convention here called the pro-max
convention where all the sort of smaller
television markets come together and
pictionary is going to be um
a game show that i do a daily game show
uh based on a show a game called
pictionary where you draw a picture
if you don't know what pictionary is you
click come out of the come out of the
rock you're under
in the desert um yeah it's really fun
it's just pictionary on on tv from
hosting talk shows game shows acting in
movies tv shows it's time for jerry to
be recognized i've never won an award
i've never won an award never i won a
razzy for a movie i was in
but i've never won
and i guess that's a real award i don't
want to offend the razzies but um i
would like to win i would like to win a
daytime emmy we do a lot of good work on
the talk and i think we're we're
deserving of it jiri has had quite the
journey so far and has an even deeper
appreciation for the jobs he's been
given when everyone heard you were
coming here today everyone kind of
resonates with different jerry's i mean
even lance back here like jerry maguire
and then someone else in here stand by
me and i like kangaroo jack like there's
something for everyone that you do do
you just have so much fun getting into
all these different roles
yeah it is fun you know um
careers are fun
just when you think they're over they're
not you know it's
it's funny i um
i don't know if it's because i'm older
but i just don't worry about like
just don't worry about it anymore like
again like coming out of the pandemic
like i was pretty abjectly
unemployed and then
just
one job led to another job led to
another job and now it's just crazy how
it happens it's um
so interesting
that was fun